So we watched an episode of The Marvelous Mrs. Maisel. I do love that show. It's a great show. Oh yeah? Have you watched it? Of course I've watched that show. Welcome to ADSP The Podcast, episode 22, recorded on April 17th, 2021. My name is Connor, and today with my co-host Bryce, we talk about our favorite technology TV shows. One, it's the same folks that created Gilmore Girls, which is a show that I really loved as a kid because it was a show about a single parent, only child,
我们看了一集《了不起的麦瑟尔夫人》。我确实很喜欢那部剧。那是一部很棒的剧。哦，是吗？你看过吗？我当然看过那部剧。欢迎收听 ADSP 播客第 22 期，录制于 2021 年 4 月 17 日。我是 Connor，今天我和我的联合主持人 Bryce 一起聊聊我们最喜欢的科技类电视剧。首先，它的制作团队和《吉尔莫女孩》是同一拨人，那是我小时候非常喜欢的一部剧，因为它讲的是一个单亲妈妈和独生女的故事，
who lived in Connecticut, and I was a single parent, a single child, an only child, with a single parent that lived in Connecticut. And did, like, ridiculous rich white people stuff, and that was also my childhood. Damn, so this is definitely going in the episode that bryce my my my my mother my mother at this at this junction would uh would feel the need to correct me and say we were never rich bryce we were upper middle class well not mom mom if you're listening to, relative to most of the people in the world, I had a pretty good childhood. Pretty good childhood. So wait, so we did lose all of our audience.
她们住在康涅狄格州，而我当时也是一个住在康涅狄格州的单亲家庭里的独生子。她们做了一些富有的白人会做的荒唐事，那也是我的童年。天哪，这段对话肯定会被剪进这一期节目里。Bryce，我妈在这个时候肯定会忍不住纠正我，说我们从来都不富有，Bryce，我们只是中产阶级上层。好吧，妈，如果你在听的话，相对于世界上大多数人来说，我有一个相当不错的童年。相当不错的童年。等等，所以我们确实失去了所有的听众。
Actually, maybe 10%, 20% know what the Gilmore Girls are. I myself have three sisters. I just thought that you meant that like the quality of our past few episodes oh no no all of our audience i mean they don't know they don't know what you what we are talking about um so bryce would you explain no no no no if you know you you you started on some analogy about your three older sisters i want to hear it go well no all i was going to say is that i know what the gomer girls are because we used to vote as the four children. We would vote on what we were going to watch.
其实，也许有 10% 到 20% 的人知道《吉尔莫女孩》是什么。我本人有三个姐妹。我刚才还以为你是说我们过去几期节目的质量……哦不，不，我是说我们的听众根本不知道我们在聊什么。嗯，Bryce，你能解释一下吗？不，不，不，你刚才开始用你三个姐姐做类比，我想听听那个。好吧，不，我只是想说，我知道《吉尔莫女孩》是因为我们四个孩子以前经常投票。我们会投票决定要看什么。
And as a 25% population representing the male children, I consistently always lost. So 4 p.m. was Oprah. I don't know what else we watched. Oh, yeah, Martha Stewart. that didn't turn out too well i know how to make lots of cupcakes though and um and yeah yeah i saw the uh the cupcakes and muffins he sent me a picture of oh yeah on twitter yeah those look good crushed it i was looking i was looking for something to critique and i like couldn't find anything so i'm like connor i want to see the inside i want to make sure that I want to make sure you baked well.
作为占人口 25% 的男性成员，我总是输。所以下午 4 点是《奥普拉脱口秀》。我不知道我们还看了什么。哦，对了，还有玛莎·斯图尔特。那次做得不太好，但我学会了做很多纸杯蛋糕。嗯，对了，我看到了你发给我的纸杯蛋糕和松饼的照片。哦，对了，在推特上，看起来不错，做得真棒。我当时正想找点什么来挑剔一下，结果什么也没找到，所以我说，Connor，我想看看里面，我想确保你烤得很好。
I looked at the inside and I'm like, damn, it did bake well. Your response to words good bake, period. I was just like. I was just like looking for something, anything. What is this, MasterChef? Yeah. But so in a nutshell, in a nutshell, Gilmore Girls is is a is a kitschy show about a a single mother who had a daughter when she was a teenager who unintentionally got pregnant, had a daughter. Now, her daughter is a teenager, too, and they both live in uh connecticut um and if you if you don't live if you're not from connecticut or new england it's kind of hard to understand um uh or appreciate
我看了里面，心想，天哪，确实烤得很好。你对“烤得好”这几个字的评价，句号。我当时只是想找点什么，随便什么都行。这是《顶级厨师》吗？是啊。总之，简单来说，《吉尔莫女孩》是一部关于一位单亲妈妈的通俗剧，她在十几岁时意外怀孕生下了一个女儿。现在，她的女儿也是个十几岁的孩子了，她们都住在康涅狄格州。如果你不住在康涅狄格州或新英格兰地区，可能有点难理解，
the show really fully but uh they do like they have a very typical connecticut lifestyle where there's like they have affluent grandparents. They're not super affluent themselves. And the daughter's very smart. And yeah, that's the show. Gets into Yale, correct? Yeah. We just ruined it.
或者说很难完全欣赏这部剧。但她们确实有一种非常典型的康涅狄格州生活方式，比如她们有富裕的祖父母。她们自己并不是特别富裕。而且女儿非常聪明。是的，这就是这部剧。考上了耶鲁，对吧？是啊。我们刚把剧情剧透了。
Yeah, and the mother runs an inn. Yeah, and her dad runs, the mother runs an inn. Yeah, and her dad runs like a little coffee shop, right? No, the boyfriend, the boyfriend, the guy becomes a stepdad. I guess that also ruins it. Yeah, sorry, spoiler alert, if you haven't watched Gilmore Girls, we just ruined like two of the three main things that we could spoil. Oh, whoops. Well, I mean, I wouldn't recommend it as a show
是啊，妈妈经营着一家旅馆。是啊，她爸爸经营着……妈妈经营着一家旅馆。是啊，她爸爸经营着一家小咖啡店，对吧？不，是男朋友，那个后来成为继父的男人。我想这也剧透了。是啊，抱歉，剧透预警，如果你还没看过《吉尔莫女孩》，我们刚刚把三个主要看点中的两个给剧透了。哦，糟了。好吧，我是说，我不会推荐这部剧，
because I never really was a big fan. It was a bonding thing from my mom and I. Like when I was like 10 or 11 before she married my stepdad, it was like, I don't know, it was a bonding thing. Well, I mean, we weren't planning on talking about Gilmore Girls. How did that even come up? Oh, because we're talking about Marvelous Miss Maisel. Yeah, the same writer, producer, whose name escapes me,
因为我从来都不是它的忠实粉丝。它是我和妈妈之间的一种情感纽带。就像我 10 岁或 11 岁，在她嫁给我继父之前，那是一种情感纽带。好吧，我是说，我们本来没打算聊《吉尔莫女孩》。这话题是怎么出来的？哦，因为我们在聊《了不起的麦瑟尔夫人》。是啊，同一个编剧兼制片人，名字我忘了，
that I am desperately Googling. uh amy sherman paladino yeah she also created marv bosmas mazel which is about like a jewish female comedian in the like 50s or 60s which is another show that i coming from a family of new york, deeply connect with. Yeah, I feel like the same way when I watch Silicon Valley, I think everyone can watch that show and find it funny. But if you actually do work in tech or adjacent to tech, there's a bunch more jokes in there that might fly over your head. I feel like I watch Marvelous Mrs. Maisel and I find it very, very funny. But there's also a bunch of like other jokes that I
我正在拼命谷歌。哦，Amy Sherman-Palladino。是啊，她也创作了《了不起的麦瑟尔夫人》，讲的是 50 或 60 年代一位犹太女喜剧演员的故事，这也是一部我作为一个来自纽约家庭的人，能产生深刻共鸣的剧。是啊，我感觉我在看《硅谷》时也是这样，我觉得每个人都能看懂并觉得好笑。但如果你真的在科技行业或相关领域工作，里面会有很多梗是你可能没注意到的。我觉得我看《了不起的麦瑟尔夫人》时觉得非常非常有趣。但里面也有很多其他的梗，
I don't I don't understand that they're happening because I I'm not Jewish and I don't understand like what it means um you know I um there's a show I really dislike in that sort of category of shows about you know tech and science people and nerds and that's the Big Bang Theory I I really dislike that show. And I'll tell you why, because I think it promotes, like, the main characters who are supposed to be these, like, nerdy guys are supposed to be, like, the protagonists of the show. And so in some ways, it's, like, good because, you know, it shows them as being, you know, the main characters of the protagonist.
我不知道它们在发生，因为我不是犹太人，我不明白那意味着什么。嗯，你知道，有一部我非常不喜欢的这类关于科技、科学人士和书呆子的剧，那就是《生活大爆炸》。我真的非常不喜欢那部剧。我会告诉你原因，因为我觉得它宣扬了……那些本应是书呆子类型的主角，本应是剧中的主角。所以从某种程度上说，这很好，因为它展示了他们作为主角的形象。
But I also think it, like, promotes a lot of, like, negative stereotypes because, like, not everybody who is in science or academia or tech is, you know, this awkward sort of nerd type. And the main character, Leonard, he's like the most, I'm going to say, quote unquote, normal of the group. And he like dates the, you know, the waitress character. And sort of, he's supposed to be like the most common man of the group. But like under the hood, he's like very much a sort of this stereotypical nerd too so I
但我也认为它宣扬了很多负面刻板印象，因为并不是每个从事科学、学术或科技工作的人都是那种笨拙的书呆子类型。主角 Leonard，他是这群人里最“正常”的一个。他和那个女服务员角色约会。他本应是这群人里最普通的一个。但实际上，他骨子里也是那种典型的书呆子，所以我
feel like the show sort of promotes this stereotype that like oh yeah everybody's like really smart and tech is sort of like the stereotypical geek who wears glasses and even the ones that sort of seem normal like under the hood this is who they are whereas silicon valley i feel like there's a lot more depth to the characters um and i feel like they do a much better job of capturing both the ridiculous stuff that goes on in silicon valley but also of making um you know of making all the making it clear that like not everybody who's in tech is just you know the stereotypical nerd um i mean the the the ceo character in silicon valley he has like a lot of the you know socially awkward problems too but like he there's a lot of depth to his character throughout the show um we can uh we can talk about tv shows for a bit if you want because i
觉得这部剧宣扬了一种刻板印象，即“哦，是的，每个人都很聪明，科技人员就是那种戴眼镜的典型极客”，即使是那些看起来正常的人，骨子里也是这样。而《硅谷》我觉得角色深度要深得多，而且他们做得更好，既捕捉到了硅谷发生的荒唐事，也明确表示并不是每个从事科技工作的人都是典型的书呆子。我是说，硅谷里的 CEO 角色也有很多社交尴尬的问题，但他在整部剧中有很多深度。我们可以聊聊电视剧，如果你想的话，因为我
basically watch every tech tv show i will say though like i i'm not a big fan of big bang although in general i'm not a big fan of like the 30 minute sitcom kind of shows but yeah i've never i've never really liked that show for the same for the same reasons um have you seen the show have you speaking of 30 minutes it comes have you seen the tv show weeds no i've not um okay so so weeds is a show about a widowed mother who uh becomes a pot dealer um and it's uh very violent and sexually explicit. And I tell you those two things because that's the context you need for this next story, which is I'm on our Passover family Zoom call with my whole family and my grandparents, who are like 92 and 88.
基本上看了每一部科技类电视剧。不过我要说，我不是《生活大爆炸》的粉丝，虽然我通常不太喜欢 30 分钟的情景喜剧。但是的，我从来没喜欢过那部剧，原因也是一样的。说到 30 分钟情景喜剧，你看过电视剧《单身毒妈》吗？没有。好吧，所以《单身毒妈》讲的是一位丧偶的母亲成为大麻贩子的故事，而且非常暴力和色情。我告诉你这两点是因为这是你理解下一个故事所需的背景，那就是我正在和全家人以及我 92 岁和 88 岁的祖父母进行逾越节家庭 Zoom 通话。
And we're talking about TV shows, and they mentioned that they've started watching Weeds. And everybody just falls silent. And it would be as if your grandparents had said like, they're like, you know, they're watching the same, you know, raunchy, you know, sexually explicit movie that you've watched is a guilty pleasure. And it was just like a super awkward conversation.
我们在聊电视剧，他们提到他们开始看《单身毒妈》了。所有人都沉默了。这就好比你的祖父母说他们正在看你当作“罪恶快感”的那种低俗、色情的电影一样。那真是一场超级尴尬的对话。
Anyways, TV shows, tech TV shows. Have you seen Halt and Catch Fire? Oh my goodness. So, okay. This, this episode is definitely, we can record two right now if you want, but this one's definitely going to be called like, I don't know, TV shows or tech TV shows. So I'll let you say whatever you're about to say about Halt and Catch Fire. But like, so I'll go through my top,
总之，电视剧，科技类电视剧。你看过《奔腾年代》吗？天哪。所以，好吧。这一期节目绝对……如果我们想的话，现在就可以录两期，但这一期肯定会被命名为，我不知道，电视剧或科技类电视剧。所以我让你说你想说的关于《奔腾年代》的一切。但，我会过一遍我的顶级……
I think there's like eight tech TV shows that I really, really like. And I'm not sure if it's number one, but Halt and Catch Fire is definitely top three. And it's a TV show that I found that like the most number of like folks haven't heard about it. It's like everyone's heard of Mr. Robot.
我觉得大概有八部我非常非常喜欢的科技类电视剧。我不确定它是不是第一名，但《奔腾年代》绝对排在前三。这是一部我发现大多数人还没听说过的电视剧。每个人都听说过《黑客军团》。
Everyone's heard of Silicon Valley. But a large number of folks haven't heard of Halt and Catch Fire. It's four seasons. I've actually seen it twice because I enjoyed it so much. And just last week, I was talking to a guy who was responsible for all of like the code and a lot of the like any code that you would see on screen and any scenes that were very like code driven, he was responsible for. And he drove like a lot of the subplots with respect to like the technology stories. And he asked me at the beginning of the call, he's like, oh, have you ever have you ever seen a show called Halt and Catch Fire? And I was like, have I seen it?
每个人都听说过《硅谷》。但很多人没听说过《奔腾年代》。它有四季。我其实看了两遍，因为我太喜欢了。就在上周，我和一个负责屏幕上所有代码以及任何代码驱动场景的人聊天，他负责那些场景。他推动了许多关于科技故事的子情节。他在通话开始时问我，他说：“哦，你看过一部叫《奔腾年代》的剧吗？”我说：“我看过吗？”
Like, that's like one of my favorite TV shows ever. And he's like, oh, like I wrote all the code for that. And I was like, what? Anyways. Now, I have a feeling I'm not the only person who does this whenever there's a show a scene in a tv show where there's like code or on the screen or there's some like panel that has information or like even if it's like a document i will pause it to go and i will pause it right there so that I can go see if it's bullshit or not.
“那是我最喜欢的电视剧之一。”他说：“哦，我为那部剧写了所有的代码。”我说：“什么？”总之。现在，我有种感觉，我不止一个人会这样做：每当电视剧里出现代码、屏幕上有信息，或者即使是一个文档，我都会暂停，暂停在那里，这样我就可以去看看它是胡扯还是真的。
And it's like it's interesting for the code. It's very oftentimes very bullshitty. One of the nice things about Halt and Catch Fire and Mr. Robot is they both don't put complete gibberish up. But we should also explain. So Halt and Catch Fire is a show set in. Is it the 80s or the the late 70s early 80s it's it's uh it starts around the time that like home computers and like uh bring home computers and i believe that's like late 70s yeah it's like it's at it's a show that starts engineers and tech business folks who, you know, try to launch the next big revolutionary product sort of in that time period.
代码方面很有趣。通常非常胡扯。关于《奔腾年代》和《黑客军团》的一件好事是，它们都没有放完全乱码的东西。但我们也应该解释一下。所以《奔腾年代》是一部背景设定在……是 80 年代还是 70 年代末 80 年代初？它开始于家用电脑出现的时候，我相信那是 70 年代末。是的，它开始于工程师和科技商业人士试图在那个时期推出下一个伟大的革命性产品。
And there's a various series of different companies and startups that they do and there's like there's sort of like one character who's sort of like a steve jobs-esque um uh marketing guy i don't really know if there's like a wozniak equivalent yeah yeah i don't i don't remember his name but like the main the main uh engineer that is like becomes really good friends with joe i'm terrible oh yeah yeah that's the thing is though like a lot of the characters like are are loosely molded after like actual people in history but like a lot of them they fuse like characteristics of like a few different people so it's it's not it's not based on a true story but it is based on like true
他们经历了一系列不同的公司和初创企业，有一个角色有点像史蒂夫·乔布斯式的营销人员。我真的不知道有没有沃兹尼亚克的对应人物。是啊，我不记得他的名字了，但那个和 Joe 成为好朋友的主要工程师……我太差劲了。哦，对了，这就是重点，很多角色都是松散地模仿历史上的真实人物，但他们融合了几个不同人的特征，所以它不是基于真实故事，但它是基于真实
history um and yeah i checked up the wik Wikipedia and it says it takes place over the 80s and the early 90s, over the dawn of like, yeah, personal computing. And interestingly, and I wonder when the show came out, what they, sort of the main, the one who I would argue is the most like, technical, like the engineer,
历史。嗯，我查了维基百科，它说故事发生在 80 年代和 90 年代初，也就是个人计算时代的黎明。有趣的是，我想知道这部剧是什么时候出的，那个我称之为最像技术人员、工程师的人，
the one who's like the technical whiz kid is this, like, female hacker, which I... Cameron. Yeah, Cameron, yeah. I liked that the show did not... Like, I liked that the show chose to not, like not have an all-male cast. Although now that I'm looking at when it was produced, it was produced in 2014, so it's not super surprising that they were thinking of that. But it's a show where they very easily could have just had no women in the show, but they chose to make one of the main female characters,
那个技术天才是一个女性黑客，我……Cameron。是啊，Cameron。我喜欢这部剧没有……我喜欢这部剧选择不让演员阵容全是男性。虽然现在我看看它是什么时候制作的，它是 2014 年制作的，所以他们考虑到这一点并不令人惊讶。但这是一部完全可以没有女性角色的剧，但他们选择让其中一个主要角色是女性，
one of the main female characters, one of the main characters female, and it adds a lot of interesting dynamics to the show. Yeah, apparently, so the same individual I mentioned that wrote all the code, apparently Cameron was originally written as male, and he, like, pushed to have it changed, which I think is, like, she's one of my favorite characters in the whole show.
其中一个主要角色是女性，这给剧集增加了很多有趣的动态。是啊，显然，我提到的那个写代码的人说，Cameron 最初被写成男性，是他推动了这一改变，我觉得她是整部剧里我最喜欢的角色之一。
Yeah. A part of her character is like navigating because she's ends up being like the tech lead on both her like first software project and then on her future projects when they're like building out their companies. And there's like a dynamic there of like her having to manage, you know, just basically a fraternity of guys. Yeah. Which is I think it makes the show so much more interesting yeah and it's it's interesting because there's you know there's there's she's definitely like harassed at certain points in the show and like has to deal with a lot of bullshit and um i like that the show does a a good job like the show isn't just like a glorification of the culture of like that late 70s early 80s um uh era like it does a good job of exposing some of the warts of that time period i think um and i think they wouldn't do as effective a job if if cameron had been cast as a
是啊。她角色的一部分是关于如何驾驭，因为她最终成为了她第一个软件项目以及后来项目中的技术主管。这里有一种动态，她必须管理一群男人。是啊。我觉得这让这部剧有趣多了。是啊，这很有趣，因为她确实在剧中的某些时刻受到骚扰，不得不处理很多烂事。我喜欢这部剧做得很好的一点是，它不仅仅是对 70 年代末 80 年代初那种文化的美化，它很好地揭露了那个时代的一些弊端。我觉得如果 Cameron 被选为
male character um now the mr robot i i, I actually didn't have that on my list because I think of that a little bit less in this category of Silicon Valley and Halt and Catch Fire because it's not about the tech industry itself necessarily. But I really like that show, and I think I like it for the same reason I like Silicon Valley is that I think the protagonist in Mr. Robot is not presented as sort of the stereotypical nerd. And in fact, he's presented as another sort of archetype from the tech world that I think most people outside of the tech world maybe aren't familiar with, which is sort of the hacker or the programmer who has a strong, who does what they do out of strong moral
男性角色，他们就不会做得这么有效。现在，《黑客军团》，我其实没把它列在我的名单上，因为我觉得它在《硅谷》和《奔腾年代》这一类中稍微弱一点，因为它不一定完全关于科技行业本身。但我真的很喜欢那部剧，我想我喜欢它的原因和喜欢《硅谷》一样，因为我觉得《黑客军团》的主角并没有被塑造成典型的书呆子。事实上，他被塑造成了科技界另一种原型，我觉得大多数科技界以外的人可能不熟悉，那就是那种有强烈道德信念的黑客或程序员，
convictions, you know, sort of that they're maybe like hacker activist is the term. Although I guess in his case, maybe he's more on the hacker terrorist side of things. But I think it does a really good job of portraying somebody that's in tech, that's a hacker who is motivated by, you know, he's not somebody who's going and playing Dungeons and Dragons on the weekend. Like, that's not what gets him up every day. Like, he wants to go and fight the evils in the world and do good. Yeah. do good um yeah yeah mr robot it starts off in the first season with like more tech focused and like hacker focused but then in the later seasons honestly it becomes more like like there's a whole economic like subplot with cryptocurrencies and corporations and income inequality but yeah mr mr robot's fantastic yeah and just to revisit halt and
你知道，也许是“黑客活动家”这个词。虽然我想在他的案例中，也许他更偏向于黑客恐怖分子那一面。但我认为它在刻画一个科技界的人、一个由……驱动的黑客方面做得非常好，他不是那种周末去玩《龙与地下城》的人。那不是他每天起床的动力。他想去对抗世界上的邪恶，做善事。是啊，做善事。是啊，是啊，《黑客军团》第一季更侧重于科技和黑客，但后来的几季，老实说，它变得更像……有一个关于加密货币、公司和收入不平等的经济子情节。但《黑客军团》太棒了。是啊，再回到《奔腾年代》，
catch fire so yeah there's uh joe mcmillan is like the steve jobs character gordon clark is the engineer which is quote unquote steve wozniak ish uh cameron howe is the lead female engineer but then also donna clark is gordon clark's wife i completely forgot about and she's like she also plays like a massive like they're the four main characters of the whole show and so uh and i think she's like so well acted in that yeah i mean all of it is amazing but her character like it shows her like uh like they're raising a family they're having marital problems but then also she is like a brilliant engineer and at times is basically providing like Gordon with the solutions to like their problems.
Joe MacMillan 是史蒂夫·乔布斯式的角色，Gordon Clark 是工程师，也就是所谓的史蒂夫·沃兹尼亚克式人物。Cameron Howe 是女性首席工程师，但还有 Donna Clark，Gordon Clark 的妻子，我完全忘了她。她也是……他们是整部剧的四个主要角色。我觉得她的演技太好了。是啊，我是说整部剧都很棒，但她的角色展示了她……比如他们抚养家庭，有婚姻问题，但同时她也是一位出色的工程师，有时基本上是为 Gordon 提供解决问题方案的人。
And like really she's the hero of the day, but she's behind the scenes. But that ends up – anyways, I don't want to give away the whole show. But highly recommend Halt and Catch Fire. I think it's like probably, like I said, the number one least well-known tech show. And I don't know what my full rankings are devs also is a new um tv show by alex garland he's the director behind ex machina oh man it's so um i absolutely it's like an eight episode or ten episode single season show and it stars uh what's his name from parks and rec yeah nick offerman and speaking of speaking
她真的是当天的英雄，但她是在幕后。但这最终……总之，我不想剧透整部剧。但强烈推荐《奔腾年代》。我觉得它可能是，正如我所说，最不为人知的科技类电视剧。我不知道我的完整排名是什么。《开发者》也是一部新剧，由 Alex Garland 执导，他是《机械姬》的导演。天哪，我绝对……这是一部 8 集或 10 集的单季剧，主演是……《公园与游憩》里的那个人，是啊，Nick Offerman。说到……
of well here's a tiny tangent i said that i'm not a big fan of like sitcoms like 30 you know 30 minute sitcom shows the one sitcom that i am a massive fan of and that i watched all the seasons of was parks and rec and that's because for whatever percentage of our audience watched parks and rec there's uh once again i'm not gonna remember his name um he's an accountant and he plays the have you seen parks and rec yeah yeah of course what's you know the accountant's name that is the husband or works up to being the husband of yeah um yeah i want i want to say scott uh but that's definitely not it here cast and characters um yeah ben ben wyatt yeah adam scott is the actor's name and ben wyatt plays this accountant and so the tiny context is that i i started my career as an actuary which is like
好吧，这是一个小插曲。我说过我不太喜欢情景喜剧，那种 30 分钟的情景喜剧。我唯一非常喜欢并看完了所有季的情景喜剧是《公园与游憩》，那是因为对于我们观众中看过《公园与游憩》的比例来说，又一次，我不记得他的名字了……他是个会计，他扮演……你看过《公园与游憩》吗？是啊，当然。你知道那个会计的名字吗？他是丈夫，或者后来成为丈夫的那个……是啊，我想说 Scott，但那肯定不对。演员表和角色……是啊，Ben Wyatt。Adam Scott 是演员的名字，Ben Wyatt 扮演这个会计。所以小背景是，我职业生涯开始时是一名精算师，也就是会计的数学版、书呆子版。Ben Wyatt 在这部剧里第三季出现，他的循环梗是他总是去那家会计事务所面试。
a more mathematical nerdier version of an accountant and ben wyatt in this tv show he shows up in like the third season and his like recurring joke is that he's always going and like interviewing at this one accounting office um and and you know we just finished saying how we don't like uh stereotypes being promoted but and this is what this sort of subplot does. And so Ben Wyatt is viewed as this like really, really cool accountant, that like whenever he goes and interviews at this office, all these sort of older, nerdier accountants think he's just like the coolest guy ever. And like the apex or the epitome of the joke is that he designed this
你知道，我们刚才说我们不喜欢宣扬刻板印象，但这正是这个子情节所做的。所以 Ben Wyatt 被视为一个非常非常酷的会计，每当他去那家事务所面试时，所有那些年长、书呆子气的会计都觉得他是最酷的人。这个笑话的巅峰是他设计了这个
game called the cones of Dunshire that is like super mathematical and that everyone thinks is lame but he brings it to the accounting office or somehow and it ended up being like the number one uh game recommended by accountants and they actually had a copy and then he was like you guys have cones of dunshire the hell they're playing cones of dunshire hey you invented that game. Um, excuse me. How did you guys get your hands on this game? Someone sent it to us. Have you played it? I invented Cones of Dunshire.
叫《Cones of Dunshire》的游戏，超级数学化，每个人都觉得很无聊，但他把它带到了会计事务所，结果它最终成了会计们推荐的第一名游戏。他们竟然有一份拷贝，然后他说：“你们有《Cones of Dunshire》？见鬼。”他们在玩《Cones of Dunshire》。嘿，你发明了那个游戏。嗯，打扰一下。你们是怎么弄到这个游戏的？有人寄给我们的。你玩过吗？我发明了《Cones of Dunshire》。
You're the architect? Yeah, right. And I'm the alchemist of the Hinterlands. Can't be an alchemist of the Hinterlands. The Hinterlands is a shadow kingdom that can only sustain a provost or a denier. He's right. Hey, how about this? Let's play. If I win, you give me another shot at free wireless for Pawnee.
你是建筑师？是啊，没错。我是边境的炼金术士。不能是边境的炼金术士。边境是一个只能维持教务长或否定者的影子王国。他是对的。嘿，这样吧？我们来玩。如果我赢了，你再给我一次为 Pawnee 提供免费无线网络的机会。
Have a seat. You want to be corporal or a warrior? Neither. I'm the Maverick. Looks like someone's out of resource gems. Uh-oh. You made one crucial mistake. You forgot about the essence of resource gems. Uh-oh. You made one crucial mistake. You forgot about the essence of the game. It's about the cones.
坐下吧。你想当士兵还是战士？都不是。我是特立独行者。看起来有人资源宝石用完了。哦哦。你犯了一个关键错误。你忘了资源宝石的精髓了。哦哦。你犯了一个关键错误。你忘了游戏的精髓了。关键在于圆锥。
Move my abbot to the ocean hex, which moves my brinkspan to the devil's lair and pushes my farmer, yes, my humble farmer,in to the devil's lair and pushes my farmer yes my humble farmer directly into the central cone anyways it's probably that nobody thought that was entertaining but just like i i i really identified with ben wyatt because i always thought of myself as like the cool actuary but like amongst normal folks that aren't nerds you know they're it's they're still pretty you know not that funny or cool but then in their little circle you feel cool um anyways nick offerman and a tangent plays uh this like billionaire person and devs i won't say more um and it's based it's based on it's
把我的住持移到海洋六边形，这把我的 Brinkspan 移到了魔鬼巢穴，并把我的农民，是的，我卑微的农民，推到了魔鬼巢穴，并把我的农民，是的，我卑微的农民，直接推到了中央圆锥。总之，可能没人觉得这很有趣，但我真的很有共鸣，因为我一直认为自己是酷精算师，但在不是书呆子的普通人中间，你知道，他们仍然觉得这不太好笑或不酷，但在他们的小圈子里，你会觉得很酷。总之，Nick Offerman 在一个插曲里扮演了这个亿万富翁，在《开发者》里，我不多说了……它是基于……它是基于
based in san francisco slash silicon valley and, and it is all about, like, quantum theory. I don't even – it's, like, it's above my head. But it's, like, you know, the – what do they call it? The multiple worlds, and they're playing off of, like, you know, is it possible to go back in time? Oh, wow. That's not a lot of what I expected. I guess I'll have to add it to my list of stuff to watch. Yeah, it's crazy like that's the thing is it's based on it's a startup called amaya and they have this like special part department of their company and then a bunch
旧金山/硅谷，全是关于量子理论的。我甚至……这超出了我的理解范围。但它是，你知道，他们称之为什么？多重世界，他们利用了，你知道，回到过去是否可能？哦，哇。这和我预期的不太一样。我想我得把它加到我的待看清单里了。是啊，太疯狂了，这就是重点，它基于一家叫 Amaya 的初创公司，他们公司有一个特殊的部门，然后发生了一堆
of stuff ensues anyways so yeah mr robot halt and catch fire silicon valley devs you know the the whole family dynamic with um uh donna and the the husband his name i'm not gonna remember in halt and catch fire gordon yeah that's one of the things that i uh like about that show that i dislike about silicon valley and um and uh the big bang theory for silicon valley i sort of understand it they're it. They're trying to portray the typical startup, which is a bunch of 25-year-old something guys. But I think it's bad for our industry if the perception is that everybody in tech and everybody that works at an early phase phase startup is a 25 year old something that you know doesn't have a family or kids um and like throughout that entire show they're always like working under these crazy deadlines and they're spending like all their time working on you know on the uh on the startup and at no point is there really any character where that has a family and where
事情。总之，是的，《黑客军团》、《奔腾年代》、《硅谷》、《开发者》。你知道，Donna 和她丈夫（名字我记不住了）在《奔腾年代》里的家庭动态，那是这部剧我喜欢的一点，也是我讨厌《硅谷》和《生活大爆炸》的一点。对于《硅谷》，我多少能理解，他们试图描绘典型的初创公司，也就是一群 25 岁左右的家伙。但我认为如果大众认为科技界和早期初创公司的每个人都是 25 岁左右、没有家庭或孩子的人，这对我们行业是不利的。
sort of the trade-off of um like work-life balance is portrayed in that show um and like the reality is that most people in tech aren't a 22 year old um uh guy that's living in, you know, some tech incubator with a bunch of other 22 year old guys, like most people in tech probably have a family, you know, probably have kids, probably have a life outside of their work. And I wish we had more TV shows that portrayed that and that portrayed the, um, the challenge between, um, you know, uh, balancing, you know, your commitment to work that you're really passionate about and your commitment to your family. Yeah. It's, it's a, it's an amazing show for, for so many reasons. And that's the thing is like, based on that explanation, it sounds like sort of like, oh, it's like a family.
在整部剧中，他们总是处于疯狂的截止日期下，把所有时间都花在初创公司上，没有任何角色有家庭，也没有描绘工作与生活平衡的权衡。现实是，大多数科技从业者不是住在科技孵化器里、和一群 22 岁小伙子住在一起的 22 岁小伙子。大多数科技从业者可能有家庭，有孩子，有工作之外的生活。我希望我们有更多描绘这一点的电视剧，描绘在对工作的热情和对家庭的承诺之间取得平衡的挑战。是啊，这是一部了不起的剧，原因有很多。基于那个解释，听起来好像是“哦，这就像一个家庭”。
It's, it's not at all. Like it's, it it's just a show it's like probably one of the most techie shows in terms of um the subplots and stuff and and the code and the projects that they're developing um but it just it doesn't cut out all the rest of the stuff that actually happens in like real life um and they don't they don't just they don't just add it in because that's the other thing is there's some shows these days that are just trying to check boxes. And so they'll add some character or they'll add some subplot just to check a box. Like this show doesn't do that at all. Like it integrates everything and all of it is just fantastic. Like, I mean, yeah, there's one scene in that show where like he's trying to get home and needs to buy some,
根本不是。这可能是在子情节、代码和他们开发的各种项目方面最硬核的科技剧之一。但它没有删掉现实生活中发生的其他事情。而且他们不是为了凑数才加进去的，因为现在有些剧只是为了完成任务。所以他们会加一些角色或子情节来凑数。这部剧完全没有这样做。它整合了一切，而且一切都非常棒。我是说，是啊，剧里有一个场景，他试图回家，需要买一些，
I can't remember if it's a gift for a birthday, but it's some doll that like his daughters want or one of his daughters wants. And he's like trying to get something done at work and then ends up you know, it's the long weekend and he's like driving around, you know, late and all the stores are closed. Anyways, there's just something very like there's something very like, oh, yeah, like that's a real thing where you're trying to do two things work and then balance something else and then something slips and it shows like how he's just so frustrated about the whole thing because it's not that. Yeah. Anyways, it's. Yeah. Yeah. No, I mean, like I'm sure most of us in tech have have had to deal with those, you know, those struggles. You know, I remember that that very vividly from what catch fire because I mean, I don't have kids, but they live in a neighborhood in Florida where all of their friends are retired.
我不记得是生日礼物还是什么，但他女儿们想要的一个玩偶。他试图在工作中完成某事，结果……那是长周末，他开车到处转，所有的商店都关门了。总之，有些东西非常真实，比如“哦，是的，这就是现实”，当你试图做两件事——工作和平衡其他事情，然后某件事搞砸了，这显示了他对整件事有多沮丧，因为事实并非如此。是啊。总之，是啊。是啊，我是说，我相信我们大多数科技从业者都经历过那些挣扎。我记得《奔腾年代》里的那个场景非常生动，因为虽然我没有孩子，但他们住在佛罗里达的一个社区，所有的朋友都退休了。
And I go and visit them every now and then. introduced to one of their friends and when I'm I say what I do like it is it's fairly common that somebody will be like oh you're like Sheldon on Big Bang Theory or something like that and like that could not be further from the truth because like one I'm not even that like deeply technical of a person um like these days, my job is mostly, you know, roadmap and vision and, you know, enabling other folks to do stuff. Like my skillset is not going and hacking a bunch of code. Like my primary skillset, I think,
我偶尔去拜访他们，被介绍给他们的一个朋友，当我告诉他们我做什么时，通常会有人说：“哦，你就像《生活大爆炸》里的 Sheldon。”那离事实太远了，因为第一，我甚至不是一个技术那么深的人。这些天，我的工作主要是路线图、愿景，以及赋能其他人去做事。我的技能不是去黑掉一堆代码。我认为我的主要技能
is like enabling other folks, mentoring other folks, and having like, building like a long-term vision for things. And it really bothers me that very often when I'm talking to somebody that's not in tech, that's just the perception that a lot of people outside of tech tend to have of us, that, oh, it's all, you know, 20-something white guys with glasses who are nerds. I'm like, that's not true. Yeah.
是赋能他人、指导他人，并为事物建立长期愿景。当我和科技界以外的人交谈时，他们对我们有这种刻板印象，即“哦，全是戴眼镜的 20 多岁白人书呆子”，这真的很困扰我。我说，那不是真的。是啊。
Yeah, I gave, I mean, I had this issue back when I was an actuary because a lot of folks never heard of that profession. So, like, yeah, it was impossible to explain. I would just say, like, insurance statistics. But, yeah, now I try not, yeah. You inevitably try to explain, oh, you work on, you know, an open source project. Like most, most people that aren't in tech haven't heard of that. And it's actually become easier now that I work at NVIDIA because everybody knows the name NVIDIA now because we've done real,
是啊，我以前做精算师时也有这个问题，因为很多人没听说过那个职业。所以，解释起来是不可能的。我只会说“保险统计”。但现在我尽量不……你不可避免地会尝试解释“哦，你在做一个开源项目”。大多数科技界以外的人没听说过。自从我在 NVIDIA 工作后，这变得容易多了，因为每个人都知道 NVIDIA 这个名字，因为我们做得很好，
like the stock has done really well over the past few years. So back when I worked at Lawrence Berkeley Labs and somebody asked me what I'd do, I'd have to say I work at Lawrence Berkeley Labs and then they'd ask me more questions and then I'd try to explain and they'd be confused. And like my family would always ask me,
股票在过去几年表现非常好。所以当我还在劳伦斯伯克利国家实验室工作时，有人问我做什么，我得说我在劳伦斯伯克利国家实验室工作，然后他们会问我更多问题，我试图解释，他们会很困惑。我的家人总是问我，
oh, well, what should I tell people you do? And I could never give them a good answer. But now I don't have to do that because I can just say I work at NVIDIA and people don't ask a lot of questions outside of that because they know what NVIDIA is at least. Yeah, I was getting delivery the other day or a couple of weeks ago
“哦，那我该告诉别人你做什么？”我从来给不出一个好的答案。但现在我不需要那样做了，因为我只需要说我在 NVIDIA 工作，人们就不会问太多问题，因为他们至少知道 NVIDIA 是什么。是啊，前几天或几周前我点外卖，
and the person from whatever app that was dropping off the food and I happened to be wearing my NVIDIA t-shirt and was like, oh, you work at NVIDIA? And I was like, yeah. And he's like, I have their products. It's the best. And I was like, that's cool when you work for a company
送餐的那个应用的人，我正好穿着 NVIDIA 的 T 恤，他问：“哦，你在 NVIDIA 工作？”我说：“是啊。”他说：“我有他们的产品。那是最好的。”我说，当你为一家人们认为在做酷事的公司工作时，那感觉真好。我有一次在飞机上遇到过这种情况，有人因为我在 NVIDIA 工作而非常兴奋，因为他们的孩子非常喜欢我们的游戏产品。好吧，好吧，但还有一件事关于电视/电影，那就是我最近在重温《终结者》。你知道，第一部《终结者》电影是在 19... 哦，天哪，什么时候？
that people associate with them, I don't know, doing cool things. I've had that happen once when I was on a plane where somebody was really excited that I worked at NVIDIA because their kid really enjoyed our gaming products. Okay, okay, but one more TV slash movie related thing, which is I've recently been re-watching Terminator. And, you know, the first Terminator movie came out in like 19... Oh, God, when?
我想是在 80 年代。因为第二部是在 92 年左右出的……等一下，我谷歌一下。1984 年，我想的没错。我觉得这非常有趣，那个时代的电影，看看视听技术对故事创作的影响。在最初的《终结者》中，他们有看起来像人类的机器人。那是相当下一代的科技。但想想他们为什么要那样做？为什么他们不在第一部里引入能变形的终结者？因为到下一部电影时，他们有了 CGI 或足够的 CGI 来实现它。但在第一部电影中，他们有一个看起来像人类的终结者。它可以模仿人类的声音。同样，模仿声音是一个很容易实现的效果。但他们无法展示太多阿诺德的外骨骼。他们无法做得很好，因为他们没有那种技术。如果今天拍那部电影，如果今天拍《终结者》，
I think it was in the 80s. Because the second one came out in like 92 um uh hang on i'll google it 1984 that's what i thought and i think it's really interesting um like movies of that era just to see how the impact of um uh of like AV tech on the story writing. So in the original Terminator, they've got these robots that look like humans. And like, that's like some pretty like next generation technology. But like, think about like, why did they do that? Why didn't they, you know, they only introduced the idea of like the Terminators that could change shape in the next movie, because by that time they had CGI or sufficient CGI to be able to do it. But in the first movie, they have this Terminator who looks like a human. It can mimic human voices. Again, pretty easy effect to do, the mimicking voices. But they couldn't really show too much of Arnold's exoskeleton. They couldn't really do a really good job of that because they didn't have the technology for it um and and like if if you know if you made that movie today if you made the terminator today
也许你不会让终结者看起来像人类，也许你会让他们成为那种你送回过去的恐怖机器人。为什么它需要伪装自己？它是一个大杀手。我可以去杀掉所有东西。但由于那个时代的限制，他们不得不做出那个选择。我喜欢看那个时代或《星球大战》的电影。是啊。
maybe you wouldn't have had the terminators look like humans maybe you would have just like had them be like you know scary robots that you sent back in time um like like what what why should it need to disguise itself like it's a big killer. I can just go kill all the things. Um, but because of the, uh, constraints of the era, they had to, uh,
嗯，我刚才在想那个。星球大战是更早的一代。有趣的是，视觉和音频效果的局限性如何导致了故事叙述本身的创新。是啊，那就是我在想的《星球大战》，每当你回去看它时，都很神奇。你看着它，心想：“是的，这显然是特效。”但对于那个时代来说，它仍然令人印象深刻。看着那些东西
to make that choice. And, uh, I, it's, I like when, when I'm watching movies of like that era or like star Wars. Yeah.
如何变化。所以，让我们做一个……因为我还有几部想开始看的电视剧，比如《星际迷航》。《星际迷航》中那么多人类看起来……或者说那么多种族看起来像人形，最简单的解释是，雇佣人类并化点妆要容易得多、便宜得多。所以他们不得不围绕那个限制来构建世界。总之，是啊，我们应该……好吧，不，让我们做一个快速的，因为我只是想抛出其他电视剧的名字，然后可能为听众选择一部非科技类的。我名单上的其余部分绝对前三名必须是《黑镜》。我绝对喜欢《黑镜》。我是说，跳过，在我看来，跳过第一季第一集，那一集是……
Um, that's what I was thinking. Star Wars earlier generation. It's just, it's interesting how the limitations of uh of visual and audio effects um uh led to innovation um in sort of in the storytelling itself yeah that that uh that's what i was thinking of star wars whenever you go back and watch it it's it's amazing to like you watch it and you're like yeah this is clearly effects and stuff but for the time it's still pretty impressive um and watching how that stuff
嗯，我当时就是这么想的。星球大战是更早的一代。有趣的是，视觉和音效的局限性反而推动了叙事本身的创新。是的，我想到星球大战时就是这种感觉，每当你回去重温它，都会觉得很神奇。你看着它会想，这显然是特效之类的东西，但以当时的水平来看，它依然令人印象深刻，看着这些东西如何...
changes so let's let's do like a because i still there's a couple tv shows that i want to start or start like star trek the fact that like so many humans in star trek look um or that so that so many races in star trek look humanoid well the very simple explanation was it's a lot easier and a lot cheaper to cast humans that you put a little makeup on and so they had to like they had to um world build around that restriction anyways yeah we should we should we should well no so let's let's do like a rapid because i just want to throw other tv show names out there and then uh potentially choose one non-tech one uh for folks so the rest on my list are definitely top three has got to be black mirror i absolutely love black mirror i mean skip in my opinion skip season one episode one that one's
发生变化。所以，我们来做个快速回顾吧，因为我还有几部想看的电视剧，比如《星际迷航》。《星际迷航》里那么多外星种族看起来都像人类，其实最简单的解释就是，找人类演员化点妆要容易且便宜得多，所以他们必须围绕这个限制来构建世界观。总之，我们应该来个快速盘点，因为我想抛出一些其他电视剧的名字，然后可能为听众选一部非科技类的。我名单上剩下的绝对前三名必须是《黑镜》，我非常喜欢《黑镜》。我的建议是，跳过第一季第一集，那一集...
absolutely awful but all the other episodes are amazing not super tech related and it's honestly not the best tv show but altered carbon i liked season one i was not happy with season two i loved season one and i was very disappointed with season two as well it basically deals with i don't know several hundred years into the future you're able to you know copy your brain onto something called a stack and so you can switch sleeves, which are just human bodies. But the more interesting part of the show that I find is it has a version of extreme income inequality, where literally the wealthy live up above the clouds, and then the rest of society is down in the earth level.
非常糟糕，但其他剧集都很棒，虽然不是特别硬核的科技题材，老实说也不是最好的电视剧，但我喜欢《碳变》第一季，对第二季不太满意。我非常喜欢第一季，对第二季也很失望。它主要讲述了大概几百年后的未来，你可以把大脑复制到一种叫“堆栈”的东西上，这样你就可以更换“义体”，也就是人类的身体。但我认为这部剧更有趣的部分在于它展现了极端的贫富差距，富人真的住在云端之上，而社会其余的人则生活在地面上。
And that's kind of interesting. There's a couple other I'm i'm missing and i'm going to be disappointed that i haven't thought of them but um i guess if they weren't at the the top of my head the one non-tech tv show that i would recommend if you haven't watched it it's not for everyone but it's one of my favorite tv shows of all time is called sense eight it's by the wachowski sisters they made the matrix and so they're a directing uh pair and it's a tv show that i think is like a decade ahead of its time it's shot across the globe in like eight different locations including like a couple different sites in north america um there's one site in africa there's one
这很有趣。还有几部我漏掉了，没能想到可能会让我感到遗憾，但如果不是脱口而出的话，有一部非科技类的电视剧，如果你还没看过，我强烈推荐。虽然它不适合所有人，但它是我有史以来最喜欢的电视剧之一，叫《超感猎杀》。它是由沃卓斯基姐妹制作的，她们制作了《黑客帝国》，所以她们是一对导演组合。我认为这部剧领先于时代十年，它在全球八个不同的地点拍摄，包括北美几个不同的地点，还有一个在非洲，有一个
site in seoul korea there's a couple in like iceland and Europe and they actually like shoot on location and all these so like like from a cinematography angle it's absolutely beautiful but I just it's a very very progressive show that is just I don't it's like it the plot is amazing but the way that like they actually have like a diverse set of like cast and sort of characters in their show is I think like the blueprint for like future shows and it's also just like the best story ever with action and whatnot and they canceled it because it was too expensive and not enough people watched it um because you can imagine flying a cast of you know whatever double digit number of people constantly around the globe so like they
在韩国首尔的拍摄点，还有几个在冰岛和欧洲。他们实际上是在实地拍摄，所以从摄影角度来看，它绝对美极了。我只是觉得这是一部非常非常前卫的剧，剧情很棒，而且他们剧中多元化的演员阵容和角色设定，我认为是未来剧集的蓝图。它也是有史以来最好的故事之一，有动作场面等等。他们取消了它，因为它太贵了，而且观看的人不够多，因为你可以想象，让两位数的演员在全球范围内不断飞行，所以他们
have to shoot it all eight or ten episodes per season, like out of order, because the way it is, is like these eight people can share basically skills and they share sort of one brain. And so one of the like there's a white guy that's a cop. There's a Korean woman who's like a martial arts expert. They're all in these individual scenarios in their own locations. But when they run into things they can like oh i need to beat someone up so i tap into the korean ladies like you know
必须把每季八到十集的剧集打乱顺序拍摄，因为剧情设定是这八个人基本上可以共享技能，共享一个大脑。所以其中有一个白人警察，还有一个韩国女性是武术专家。他们都在各自的地点面对各自的情况，但当他们遇到困难时，他们可以像“哦，我需要打倒某人，所以我调用了韩国女士的……”
martial arts skills and the way that they shoot it is just unbelievable um anyways what are your your rapid that was not super rapid what are your i think uh i think for me so obviously firefly but i think that's like that's got to be on a lot of a lot of people's lists um I really like Stargate that's out of like all of the sci-fi tv series that had like multiple series and like I had a really long run which is like I think like it's like Stargate, Star Trek, Star Wars although admittedly Stargate's not as big as those are the two. I think Stargate's maybe my favorite. And I don't know, it competes with Star Wars. I'm a really big Star Wars fan. So tell me this.
武术技能，他们拍摄的方式简直令人难以置信。总之，你的快速推荐是什么？那不太快，你觉得……我想对我来说，显然是《萤火虫》，但这肯定在很多人的名单上。我真的很喜欢《星际之门》，在所有拥有多个系列且播出时间很长的科幻电视剧中，比如《星际之门》、《星际迷航》、《星球大战》，虽然不可否认《星际之门》没有那么大名气，但这两者中，我想《星际之门》可能是我最喜欢的。我不知道，它和《星球大战》不相上下。我是一个非常大的《星球大战》粉丝。所以告诉我这个。
I tried to get, I tried to look into getting into Stargate, but like when you go to the, the, like the, you know, different series and TV, there's like an intro TV show, then like three different series and there's like an intro tv show then like three different series across like what what is like how does one start watching stargate if they haven't so watched it i i would typically if you google there's like there's viewing orders um and it's the viewing orders are complicated because two of the tv series overlapped with each other and had crossover between the two um uh So you have to watch like eight seasons of SG-1 and then switch over to watch like three seasons of Atlantis and then
我试着去了解《星际之门》，但当你去看那些不同的系列和电视节目时，有一个入门剧，然后是三个不同的系列，跨度很大。如果一个人还没看过，该怎么开始看《星际之门》呢？我通常会建议去谷歌搜索，上面有观看顺序。观看顺序很复杂，因为两部电视剧在时间上有重叠，而且两者之间有交叉。所以你必须看八季《SG-1》，然后切换到看三季《亚特兰蒂斯》，然后
switch back over. So if you Google for Stargate viewing order, there is like, there are some pretty good resources for it. We'll put it in the show notes. We'll put it in the show notes. I generally recommend you start with the movie and then you start with SG-1 and then you start watching Atlantis at the same time. But the reason that I like Stargate is it's a sci-fi TV show, but it's actually really just about anthropology and archaeology. Every episode is like they go to some planet and they do some anthropology or archaeology like that is primarily the tv show yeah there's like some parts where they're like shooting at aliens um and there's like parasitic worms that are trying to take over the galaxy but primarily it's let's go to this planet and learn about their culture.
再切回来。所以如果你谷歌搜索“星际之门观看顺序”，会有一些非常好的资源。我们会把它放在节目说明里。我们通常建议你先看电影，然后开始看《SG-1》，然后同时开始看《亚特兰蒂斯》。但我喜欢《星际之门》的原因是它是一部科幻电视剧，但实际上它更多是关于人类学和考古学的。每一集他们都会去某个星球，做一些人类学或考古学研究，这基本上就是这部剧的内容。是的，有些部分他们是在向外星人射击，还有试图接管银河系的寄生虫，但主要是“让我们去这个星球了解他们的文化”。
And, like, to some degree, Star Trek does that. But this does it in, like, a much more direct way because part of the idea of the show is that all, like, there's these humans that are interspersed all throughout the galaxy that were, like, seeded by these all-powerful aliens. And a lot of them have cultures that are similar to cultures on earth um and uh and yeah so so it's just like i i just i like how it's it's another example of how like they used a really innovative um story mechanism to make it easy for them to produce the show because like inherent to that world is the idea that, yeah, there are aliens. But also there's just a lot of humans that are distributed across the galaxy. And shooting an episode where you've got a bunch of humans is a lot easier than when you've got a bunch of aliens. Yeah, so I really like that show.
在某种程度上，《星际迷航》也做到了这一点。但这部剧以一种更直接的方式做到了，因为该剧的部分理念是，所有人类都散布在整个银河系中，是由这些全能的外星人播种的。他们中的许多人拥有与地球文化相似的文化。所以，我只是喜欢它是如何利用一种非常创新的故事机制，使他们更容易制作这部剧，因为该世界观本身就包含了一个想法：是的，有外星人，但也有很多分布在银河系的人类。拍摄一集有很多人类的剧集比拍摄有很多外星人的剧集要容易得多。是的，所以我真的很喜欢这部剧。
And I really love Westworld. Oh, yeah, yeah. Westworld, sorry. Way up there. Way up there. Way up there. I think Westworld's probably up there for like, it's got to be, it's probably my favorite TV show at least in the past decade. Really? I really love that show.
我真的很喜欢《西部世界》。哦，是的，是的。《西部世界》，抱歉。非常棒。非常棒。非常棒。我认为《西部世界》可能是我过去十年中最喜欢的电视剧。真的吗？我真的很喜欢那部剧。
Yeah. What, without spoiling it, although I'm sure there's going to be some people that start watching it because of this. How did you feel about season three? I liked season three. I know some people didn't like season three. But I very much liked it. I enjoyed seeing a wider world than in season one and two. The, yeah, I liked it.
是的。在不剧透的情况下，尽管我相信肯定会有人因为这个开始看它。你觉得第三季怎么样？我喜欢第三季。我知道有些人不喜欢第三季，但我非常喜欢。我很高兴看到比第一季和第二季更广阔的世界。是的，我喜欢它。
And it had an ending where I was like, yeah, I thought it was all well done. Did you actually, and once again, without, because I have to say, just I asked that question because season one and two I thought were amazing. And then season three, without giving anything away, it took it sort of in a new direction. And I missed sort of the feel of season one and two.
它的结局让我觉得，是的，我觉得一切都做得很好。你真的……再一次，因为我必须说，我问那个问题是因为我觉得第一季和第二季太棒了。然后第三季，在不剧透的情况下，它朝着一个新的方向发展。我怀念第一季和第二季的感觉。
And once again, yeah, without giving anything away, did you follow? It's clear by the end of season one or two like what was going on in season one but like i was so not following uh like i was enjoying the show and and i thought it was amazing and then when i got to like a certain point in the show i realized like the actual how do i say this without giving stuff away like this the storyline mechanics like were you tracking that the whole time because i was not and then when i when i found out what was going on i was like wow where are all my iq points
再一次，在不剧透的情况下，你跟上了吗？到第一季或第二季结束时，很清楚发生了什么，但我当时完全没跟上。我当时很享受这部剧，觉得它太棒了，然后当我看到剧中的某个点时，我意识到……我该怎么说而不剧透呢……比如剧情机制，你全程都在追踪吗？因为我没有，当我发现发生了什么时，我心想：哇，我的智商都去哪了？
like how have i not noticed one of the things that i like about the show is that it has um enough complexity to it that i can't always guess where exactly it's going to go and uh i think the third i i i have like many tv shows i like but i think the third show i'd i'd i'd say is um futurama um which is uh it's like an it's sort of like the simpsons it's like an animated 30 minute um uh series and it's like a comedy show and it's set in the future um and it's usually like mostly a comedy show except there's actually a lot of like really deep um uh there's a lot of really deep content there sort of under the surface um uh it's actually like there's a lot of like uh college classes uh on film get taught and use some Futurama episodes as examples. It may be the show
我喜欢这部剧的一点是，它有足够的复杂性，我不能总是猜到它到底会走向哪里。我想第三部我想说的剧是《飞出个未来》，它有点像《辛普森一家》，是一部30分钟的动画系列，是一部喜剧，背景设定在未来。它通常大部分时间是一部喜剧，但实际上表面之下有很多非常深刻的内容。实际上，有很多大学电影课程会使用《飞出个未来》的剧集作为例子。它可能是
that I've rewatched the most times. Yeah. I'm trying to get the story on... I personally have not watched Futurama. I've seen a couple episodes. The humor is not really my style, and I'm
我重看次数最多的剧。是的。我正在尝试了解关于……我个人没有看过《飞出个未来》。我看过几集。幽默感不是我的风格，而且我
pretty sure there's a bunch of folks listening being like, what? It's the best. But, like, who created it? Aren't they like, it's some crazy like Harvard geniuses or something? Um, I don't know. One of the things that I appreciated about it is
很确定有很多听众会想：什么？它是最好的。但是，是谁创作的？他们不是什么哈佛天才之类的吗？嗯，我不知道。我欣赏它的一点是
it's created by Matt Groening, the same guy who did The Simpsons. One of the reasons that I appreciate about it is, you know, it's created by Matt Groening, the same guy who did The Simpsons. One of the reasons that I like it as a show is because it definitely has, like, two levels of viewing it. You can watch it solely as a, like, a light comedy show but then there's also like a lot of episodes also have like a much like deeper um uh meaning like it's it's like a show that's like like there are episodes of futurama that will like make me emotional um and and i think that that it's pretty impressive for a comedy show to have such breath that to be able to do that yes so here from the wikipedia page it says the writing staff held three phd's seven master's degree and cumulatively more than
它是由马特·格勒宁创作的，也就是制作《辛普森一家》的那个人。我欣赏它的一点是，它绝对有两个观看层面。你可以把它仅仅当作一部轻松的喜剧来看，但很多剧集也有更深层的含义。这就像是一部剧，有些《飞出个未来》的剧集会让我感动。我认为一部喜剧能有这样的深度是非常令人印象深刻的。是的，从维基百科页面上看，它说编剧团队拥有三个博士学位、七个硕士学位，累计在哈佛大学学习了超过
50 years at harvard university series writer varone stated we're easily we were easily the most over-educated cartoon writers in history yeah so yeah that's i don't know i don't know a ton about the backstory about the backstory but i know that uh there's a lot of years of education and that's the thing is that like there's one episode that sort of went viral that was about like quantum realms and stuff or some theory and it went viral because they were like this is a better demonstration of this theory than like has ever been sort of uh demonstrated before yeah i'll try and find that episode and put a link to it if folks are yeah my definitely my my favorite episode is uh uh is one called godfellas
50年。系列编剧瓦隆说：“我们绝对是历史上受教育程度最高的动画编剧。”是的，所以我不知道关于背景故事的太多细节，但我知道他们有很多年的教育背景。有一集关于量子领域之类的理论在网上疯传，因为它被认为是对该理论比以往任何时候都更好的演示。是的，我会试着找到那一集并放一个链接。我最喜欢的一集叫《上帝的杰作》
season 3 episode 20 thanks for listening we hope you enjoyed and have a great day There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
第三季第20集。感谢收听，希望你们喜欢，祝你们有愉快的一天。这一集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子即可发表评论。